you want to a movie we'll get one of
your hit characters from the TV show
take the momentum right into a movie
you're ready I don't know here we go I
need you to know the depth of my
feelings for you I want you to know that
I would die for you
no matter what I do it what I say every
time I try to show you it says it it's
me
[Music]
did you love Frankie with his bitches
emotions this July 11 was it good for
you you want a sandwich
what mmm you want a sandwich what do you
want a sandwich
[Laughter]
how's that sandwich coming this summer
only in theaters
are you checking any luggage today sir
yourself and the bags have been in your
possession the whole time these bags
have been in your possession the whole
time
these bags were they in your possession
the whole time mr. Dillon you're all set
pardon me madam
well this be reflected upon my frequent
flyer miles did you book your flight
online have a nice flight
have a nice flight have a nice flight
whoa they have a nice light have a nice
flight
you've just watched a moment in the life
of little dude hello and good evening
it's me what it's me it's me Little John
you're like I just need to talk to
someone who will understand and well
that someone is you John okay don't you
like popsicles
what I said don't you like popsicles
like I am all alone in this world and I
have no ones who go to what I said
sometimes I feel like I'm all alone in
his world and I have no one sir
what know who to go to
huh no one that understands my pain
sometimes when I'm alone sit on my hand
wait till it gets numb and masturbators
to call that a stranger have you ever
given yourself a stranger what a
stranger hold on
they cow and me Little John it's Oprah
good
listen I'm pregnant sure it's mine
I'm sure it's yours she's having our
baby I can't hear you my cell phone's
breaking up I can't hear you
somebody your phone is breaking up what
what what what what what
what okay okay
affirmative Oh Raza yeah
what meltdown
Lil Jon then you have fractured your arm
let's take a look no yes not really no
no what about this right then you have
your proof of insurance
what what what we have insurance huh
proof of insurance
who what proof of insurance
what your proof of insurance what proof
of insurance proof of insurance
oh wow do you do any recreational drugs
recreational drugs
that depends doctor what do you define
as drugs medication no cocaine
absolutely not marijuana nothing
pardon nothing just writing I didn't say
anything be done my second call okay
you've just watched a moment in the life
of Little John the Theresa Roddy
interview here she is
Theresa Roddy now Little John I heard
that you once worked in a fast-food
restaurant and you almost made it
tonight manager is that also good
J yeah now I'm going to change the
subject a little if that's all right
with you who I would like to change the
subject
Oh change the subject good I'm gonna
change the subject if that's all right
with you and it's
a little sensitive please feel free to
stop me in my research I found out that
you had been beaten brutally by two
white police officers under mistaken
identity is that correct yes there's
true that was the first time in my life
that I'd that I ever experienced any
type of racial discrimination and I made
up my mind then and there that I would
transcend these social constraints see
madam so often but you could cast aside
by a society that is too afraid of them
to recognize the humanity my mother knew
this and she did her damnedest to make
sure that I knew it and I'm Adam through
my music
to make sure that all black you realize
the truth because to me that is an act
it's been very painful for you thank you
thank you little john-boy thank you
thank you thank you thank you thank you
no problem at home thank you for coming
to my
do you smoke Weaver yes hey you have a
little time it's for the kids
Oh ladies and gentlemen a little joke
you've just watched a moment in the life
of Little John
[Applause]
you